[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everyone to streaming the galaxy
my name is rocket reilly and today we're
going to be going over everything we
know so far about indiana jones 5. but
before we get started if you're new to
the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video
indiana jones a mild-mannered
archaeology professor with a neck for
cracking a whip is at it again with a
fifth adventure 41 years after his first
escapade in raiders of the lost ark a
fifth film in the indiana jones
franchise has been in talks ever since
the release of the kingdom of the
crystal skull in 2008 but with disney's
acquisition of lucasfilm in 2012 and
harrison ford's early skepticism about
the project it wasn't officially
announced until 2015. originally
scheduled for a 2019 release this film
has seen a few setbacks
after several changes in the film's
screenwriters and directors it was
finally set with james mangold taking on
the helm of director and place of steven
spielberg and with jez and john henry
butterworth as screenwriters
it'll be interesting to see the change
from spielberg to mangold as director
since steven spielberg has directed
every indiana jones film released so far
the numerous changes in directors and
screenwriters along with the ongoing
global pandemic and several issues on
set have pushed the release date back
quite a bit
recently harrison ford suffered a
shoulder injury during filming and over
50 people working on the film have
contracted norovirus causing further
setbacks the movie is now expected to
have a release date of july 29
and john williams will return to
continue his legacy as the indie music
composer and finish off his iconic
musical saga
we have top men working on it right now
who
top
men
at 78 years old harrison ford will
reprise his role as indiana jones the
film will also feature phoebe waller
bridge of solo a star wars story and
fleabag
mads mikkelson of doctor strange and
hannibal boyd holbrook of logan and the
predator
shawnette renee wilson of the black
panther thomas crutchman of avengers age
of ultron toby jones of captain america
and the hunger games and antonia
banderas of the mask of zorro
now i'll be honest this seems like an
incredible cast with names ranging from
star wars movies to mcu titles it'll be
great to see all of this amazing talent
on screen together
although it seems pretty unlikely mark
hamill also joked about wanting to be
the newest villain in indiana jones 5.
even though it likely won't happen just
the idea of this is exciting and i can't
wait to see if it comes true
according to several different sources
and rumors it's likely that the story
will take place in the late 60s or early
70s with at least one plot point
revolving around the 1969 moon landing
or the astronauts return
other scenes in the movie may include a
castle in england and an ss motorbike
according to pictures taken on set so it
seems that the film's specific plot will
likely be hard to pin down at least
until the first trailer is released now
this is the first time one of the
indiana jones films will be released
since disney's acquisition of lucasfilm
so it'll be interesting to see if there
are any significant changes to previous
cuts of the movies from the franchise or
anything different on screen from what
we can typically expect from an indiana
jones film although the movie is set for
a mid-2022 release date i wouldn't be
surprised if it sees further setbacks
due to the pandemic and other onset
issues
even so it might be a good idea to start
re-watching the first four installments
of the indie franchise just so you're
ready for the newest chapter
but don't worry i'll be sure to do a
video on everything you need to know
before indiana jones 5 is released so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss that
video and all of our other great content
also if you enjoyed today's video please
consider hitting the like button and if
you have ideas that you'd like to share
for future videos please drop them in
the comments section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
[Music]